what species is grogu and where is his
home planet I believe I've found the
answer in the Disney plus series The
Mandalorian we've been given several
hints about grogu or the child's species
and in this video I'll explain the
backstory of grogu's Homeworld and
upbringing most of all though I'll
explain exactly what species grogu
actually is first things first I have to
say that our lovable little baby Yoda is
not actually a young Master Yoda but
there's an interesting fan theory about
this that I'll explain later the
Mandalorian takes place after the events
of Return of the Jedi meaning that Yoda
had already passed away by this point so
grogu or baby Yoda is not a young Jedi
Master Yoda but simply an alien of the
same species according to official Star
Wars Canon Yoda's species is one of the
most mysterious in the entire galaxy
their home planet has never been
officially named but I believe I found
it Yoda was considered to be one of the
last members of his species and the only
other known member was a female named
yaddle who served as a Jedi council
member during the prequel trilogy in the
first season of the Mandalorian the
armorer mentions that she's seen another
member of grogu species or people before
which suggests that there are at least a
few more of these creatures out there in
the galaxy however aside from this there
is very little information about the
species to be found despite the lack of
information about grogu species there
are a few hints from the Mandalorian
that can give us some clues about his
background in the series it's revealed
that grogu was rescued from the Jedi
Temple during the fall of the Republic
this means that he was likely trained by
a Jedi before he was hidden away for his
own safety during his time with the
Mandalorian Goku is shown to have a
strong connection to the force which is
likely a result of his Jedi training his
use of the force is also reminiscent of
Yoda's abilities which further fuels the
idea that he's a member of the same
species another interesting detail is
the fact that grogu is able to
communicate with others through
telepathy in the Mandalorian he's seen
meditating in an attempt to contact
other Jedi and it's suggested that this
may be how he communicates with his own
kind the only other somewhat solid piece
of information we have about grogu and
Yoda species is George Lucas's
explanation when he was asked about
their kind calling Yoda the illegitimate
child of Kermit the Frog and Miss Piggy
but now for the question you've all been
waiting for what species is grogu and
what is his home planet well I believe
that grogu is from the planet Atlantic
and is a member of an indigenous species
on the planet that has a special
connection to the force lanik is a small
mid-rim planet in the Star Wars Galaxy
home to a species also called lanik the
Atlantic people resemble Yoda's species
in many ways having a short stature long
pointed ears and in some cases a top
knot of hair there are several different
skin color variations within the
Atlantic species including orange blue
purple and green just like grogu and
Yoda I believe that Yoda species is a
very small subgroup of lanik that lives
in an area on the planet with strong
ties to the force it would make sense
that this species subgroup has a longer
average lifespan and slight differences
in appearance to other Atlantic people
as they stay isolated in a force
sensitive area and have experienced
thousands of years of evolution in
different ways from other Atlantic the
reason this subgroup onlantic hasn't
been mentioned is simply because they're
so isolated and the Galaxy is so large
it certainly could be true that grogu
Yoda and yaddle all came from lanik and
went to study in the Jedi Order because
they had an above average connection to
the force it's worth noting that all of
this is just speculation but it does
provide what I believe to be the best
theory about the true Heritage of grogu
and Yoda subscribe for more Star Wars
content and if you like the video check
out this one too